thank you alejandro we are indeed with
tatev tate first of all big
congratulations for this match it was a
topsy-turvy first game it felt like you
were under tremendous pressure you
pulled the 180 in that one and won that
game but even in the second game you
were playing a very uh normal game it
doesn't seem like you have any problems
holding a draw at least and winning the
match but then things got a bit crazy
tell us about that yeah when i took on
v6 um i missed that
b a b knight a4 and she just goes rook
fba i thought i'm just like winning
material and
simplifying the position
otherwise there is no reason for me to
take on v6 because she can't do anything
on the a file
i can just play rook d2 maybe i
after king e8
oh sorry king e8 rook tv yeah i mean a
takes b6 is so rushed i just completely
forgot that the rook goes the d row goes
to b8 and then things yeah i mean she
got the kind of position you want when i
mean like she gets some chances right i
see i like the special b7 resource
and this end game yeah the sun game was
very suspicious and not pleasant
suddenly
yeah i was i was so unhappy here i was
like i can't believe this is how this
match is gonna go when i was like okay i
have a bishop
f6 and it does seem like right black uh
was supposed to play the move e6
followed by f5 try to
solidify those pawns on the light
squares were you worried about that but
i thought i could put my bishop on f6
and i just defend c3 exactly before you
play the move bishop to h4 that's when
she had the time to do e6 and then f5
but
wait where so instead of king to c6 now
e6
but then i go bishop h4 again and then
f5
but then i trade
yes
this position
it did seem like the blacking is going
to go to d5 and it becomes quite
difficult i mean probably the knight
comes to e4 right and then where's where
does the king on e2 depend upon on c3
and at some point whenever you have the
king on d3 i will give you a check
knight to b2 and then i'm going to
invade with the king it seems this is
pretty deep
even in the game we we kind of thought
that katya was still
pressing you right about these parts
yeah we thought yeah
this e5 was a tremendous move though but
no we thought that g5 was still putting
pressure on you
we thought bishop g3 yeah and then we
thought king c4 can i go h
yes this was our kind of our main
uh line of play king takes c3 you're
welcome to capture
on
how would you like to hold on so if i go
eff
e f e f yes
and then f g whoa oh my god i thought
i'm winning a pawn oh wow
i did not count properly though i'm not
even that clear here fgfg h5 for bishop
e5 check and h5 fg fg what so perhaps
instead of these guys
after king to c4 this gets complicated
but after king to c4 can't i just take
on f6 instead of h4
oh
yeah take twice
hey she has to take with the h if you
take with the h pawn then i go h4 and
then she seems to be simplifying that
that's the fast way and if you take with
this
okay that clears some cobwebs on my part
okay yeah
no but i mean in the game i found this
move that i'm very proud of
bishop to d6 yeah
and she had no times uh maybe she
decided i don't know but i think
but i think she maybe even missed that
five because um she started thinking but
i think after f5 it's already
too late yeah yeah
it was a very nice move bishop d6 yeah
i'm quite pleased with this move
who would who will tata play she'll be
playing against begging tokyo genoa who
defeated stavroula tolaquito in the
semi-finals of the elimination bracket
nice our congratulations to you
well done woof